we have to account for her generation so
she would not know to be like like hold
it over she would just it would be like
this
[Music]
welcome back to I answered the internet
oh oh wait let me I'm sorry you said so
okay hi I'm Elijah Schlesinger and I'm
answering the internet Mary [ __ ] kill
Italian food Mexican food Chinese food
these are such dude questions one is
gonna be about like pineapple on Pizza
uh well I did marry an Italian person so
I guess I have to say so we don't get a
divorce marry the Italian food uh [ __ ]
the Mexican
[ __ ] them that sounded so such a bad
sound bite
I guess I guess uh kill uh [ __ ] Chinese
food
and because there's so much okay and
then kill the Mexicans I don't have to
qualify this WOW because I live in LA so
I had so much Mexican food this is gonna
be so taken out of context cancel me
later
what three items that can fit in a fanny
pack would you choose to bring with you
to a desert island
okay well obviously hydrogen peroxide
is it just one tampon it's probably not
even worth it at that point
one big diva cup ew like no I would just
let it go and attract animal friends uh
okay uh does water count food do I have
an object do I have a VHS player driver
what's it called
imagine a VCR can I bring my husband
it's okay
[Music]
okay shut up so it's not practical okay
you want me to say a dildo
[ __ ] Buffalo beef jerky and Sports
Illustrated but the one with the bash
Brothers on the cover
please don't make that happen debate
theater are there any universally loved
movies that you hate
oh um this is not the outlet for that
because if I tell you that like I will
get hate mail say it okay no it's not
that I hate but it's like a secret
I've never seen Back to the Future
and I went to a film School
I've seen so much like French surrealist
Cinema
what why'd you watch it I'm busy I have
a baby
because I don't need to at this point a
movie next to the Future that's [ __ ]
yeah you're stupid what's worse that or
only having seen Thor Ragnarok on a
small screen on a plane like watching it
on your Apple watch don't DM me about it
I'll block you you if you were on an old
episode of room Raiders what would be
the most what would you be the most oh
what would what would you be most afraid
of being found sometimes I sometimes I
wipe boogers in weird places
where do you put them sometimes under
the bed
sometimes if it's really bad because
it's really dry in California and you
wake up you're like I guess no one will
see that until we move
oh my God she's so vulnerable and like
accessible because she's so honest I
know the answer is supposed to be like a
sex toy or something but no pull the
internet would you rather spend the rest
of your life in a country music video or
a rap music video oh disguise this but
for girls
yeah because one you're totally
objectified and the other you have no
rights over your own body
but I would pick country videos because
at least you're like relaxing in a field
you're fishing it's about like being a
home in a rap video is just up here and
your back would go out from shaking it
so while I do love both genres I pick
country uh would you rather see this
question is going to [ __ ] you
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh or have there be genocide
every time you fall in love I think
those are happening anyway so I pick
both
answer the internet would you rather
have your mom send you a nude or have
her send all your friends a nude of her
or of me
and then sister both well I've seen my
mom naked so is it like she's just like
what or is it like a nude is like but
wait like I watch
yeah but we have to account for her
generation so she would not know to be
like like hold it over she would just it
would be like this
so and it's not as upsetting right she
can send it to me that's fine I've seen
her naked and she seen me naked even
though I asked her not to would you see
me hold it
[Laughter]
if you had to move it to a different
place on the body where would you put
the vagina
maybe just like an inch back
[Music]
[Laughter]
what am I supposed to my forehead so I
can feed it no it needs to be protected
this is so hard who's your favorite
movie villain obviously Hitler oh I
missed that I'm sorry like I thought you
meant like the worst I thought you meant
like the worst oh you know who's a great
villain oh what's his name in Inglorious
Bastards like the head Nazi what's that
actor's name the the Kristoff Waltz with
like the milk scene and like I love a
glass of your delicious milk and just
being that's a good one everyone only
because I watched it recently so that's
in my mind also what's his name not
Cronus uh in Thor Ragnarok again I'm
revising it the bad guy that actually
wants to ethnic cleanse and you're like
part of you is like I kind of see your
point Who's the worst group of fans
oh most teenagers just because like
teenage girls because like they will
wreck your life because you said you
like didn't love a K-Pop song and
they're like I'll kill myself and I'll
kill you and you're just like your brain
isn't fully formed like take a beat that
being said please buy my book All Things
aside so you can learn something young
chickens
yeah
was I supposed to say like Red Fox News
is jerking off to nudes of a girl who
has died nice sorry weird or nice
tribute you can tell this listen to me
you can tell this was written by a man
because only dudes on Reddit threads are
like oh a trivia it's not a [ __ ]
tribute even if she's alive it's [ __ ]
gross your jizz is not an honor
that being said it depends on how hot
she is
you are the best thank you so much
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out